В ефірі випуск актуальних новин «heute 19 Uhr» з Мітрі Зірін.
Гарного всім вечора!
Зі мною в студії Крістін Отто з новинами спорту.
Вітаю!
Міжнародний геополітичний клімат
залишається напруженим, як ніколи.
Перейдемо до огляду сьогоднішніх тем.
Суперечливий візит:
спікерка Палати представників США Ненсі Пелосі
сьогодні прибула до Тайваню.
Китай реагує погрозами.
Удар по терору:
США ліквідували
лідера «Аль-Каїди» Аймана аль-Завахірі
ракетами з безпілотника.
Успішне повернення до Німеччини:
Маріо Ґетце приносить франкфуртському
ФК «Айнтрахт»
вихід у другий раунд Кубка Німеччини з футболу.
Наростає нова серйозна криза.
Попри численні жорсткі застереження з боку Китаю,
літак Ненсі Пелосі
приблизно дві години приземлився в Тайвані.
Спікерка Палати представників США
наразі перебуває в дипломатичному турне країнами Азії.
Проте її суперечливий візит до столиці Тайваню,
міста Тайбей,
призвів до критичного загострення відносин
між США та Китаєм.
Про можливі наслідки
розкажуть згодом наші кореспонденти
наживо з Китаю та США.
А зараз Фолькер Дучек розкаже
про передумови конфлікту.
Пекін переконаний,
що Тайвань належить до
комуністичної Китайської Народної Республіки.
Натомість Тайвань вважає себе Республікою Китай
і з 90-х років має демократично спрямоване керівництво.
Уряд перебуває  в столиці Тайбей.
На міжнародній арені
Пекін відстоює «принцип єдиного Китаю»:
країни, які прагнуть мати
дипломатичні відносини з Китаєм,
мусять вести діалог виключно з Пекіном
і не можуть мати контакти з Тайбеєм.
США теж не мають дипломатичних стосунків з Тайбеєм,
але це не заважає їм постачати
острівній республіці зброю.
Тож США є головним союзником Тайваню.
У будь-якому разі
Китай прагне возз'єднання з Тайванем,
навіть якщо доведеться застосувати зброю.
У відповідь на це президент США Байден
ще у травні заявив,
що США готові до такого розвитку подій
і готові підтримувати Тайвань.
Пелосі - політик найвищого рангу
з усіх представників США,
що відвідували з візитом Тайвань за останні 25 років.
У Міністерстві закордонних справ Китаю
вважають це «грою звогнем».
Репортаж Ульфа Роллера.
Перші кадри прибуття Ненсі Пелосі
до столиці Тайваню Тайбей.
Суперечливий та небезпечний візит,
що розпалює конфлікт
між світовими лідерами - Китаєм та Америкою.
Небезпеку цього візиту
підтверджують відеокадри,
опубліковані Міністерством оборони Китаю.
Армія відточує майстерність дій у надзвичайних ситуаціях,
але також і для вторгнення на Тайвань.
Попередження для США.
Такий візит, безперечно, дуже небезпечний.
Він ставить під загрозу мир і стабільність у регіоні.
Відповідь китайців не змусила себе чекати.
Міністерство оборони Китаю оголосило
про чотириденні військові навчання
з оточенням острова Тайвань.
Тайванці вже давно готуються до найгіршого.
В столиці проводять тестування повітряної тривоги.
Люди відпрацьовують свої дії у разі нападу Китаю.
У місті надія переплелася зі страхом.
Думаю, що у разі загострення конфлікту
США буде на нашому боці.
Зараз дуже напружений час,
будь-яка дія може загострити ситуацію.
Немає правильних і неправильних дій.
Біля узбережжя Тайваню США і Китай
пильно слідкують за кожним рухом один одного.
Для правителів Пекіна острів завжди був
частиною Народної Республіки.
США відправили до регіону
свій авіаносець «Рональд Регайн».
Вони вважають себе захисником Тайваню.
Це двобій світових держав.
Якщо Китай вирішить
спровокувати кризу чи загострити ситуацію,
винним буде Пекін.
Все ж ми сповідаємося на поміркованість Китаю.
Тайвань сподівається на допомогу Америки.
Країна тепло приймає у себе Пелосі,
незважаючи на те, що цей візит
може спричинити кризу в цілому регіоні.
Про критичність ситуації ми поговоримо з
нашими кореспондентами
з Вашингтона та Пекіна.
Ульфе Роллере, вам слово.
«Гра з вогнем» - коментар Пекіна
одразу після приземлення Пелосі.
Чи зупиниться Китай на жорсткій риториці?
Ні, навпаки.
Не лише риторика буде жорсткою,
але буквально буде відкритий вогонь.
Одразу після прибуття Ненсі Пелосі Китай повідомив
про проведення численних військових навчань
поблизу Тайваню.
Перші навчання плануються
відразу після відльоту Пелосі.
В результаті масштабних навчань
Тайвань опиниться в оточенні Китаю.
І це тільки початок.
Це свідчить про те, що Сі Цзіньпін
не кидає слів на вітер щодо своїх погроз.
Він сприймає цей візит як особисту образу, адже вважає
своєю історичною місією об'єднання з Тайванем.
А візит пані Пелосі наштовхує Сі Цзіньпіна на думку,
що Америка хоче домогтися незалежності Тайваню
і тому не дотримується
раніше узгоджених домовленостей.
Тож його реакція дуже й дуже жорстка.
Тому даний конфлікт в регіоні
залишатиметься актуальним протягом місяців,
а то й років.
Переходимо до Ельмара Тевессена.
Що робить Білий дім,
щоб запобігти подальшому загостренню ситуації?
Білий дім обрав подвійну стратегію.
З одного боку, він намагається применшити
значення візиту.
Адже протягом останніх тижнів
вже відбулися візити делегацій від Когресу й
політиків США нижчого рангу.
Насправді нічого особливого не відбулося.
Про загрозу «політиці єдиного Китаю»
мови йти не може.
Білий дім погоджується, що Китай, а не Тайвань,
є тією стороною, з якою ведуться переговори.
З іншого боку, Білий дім хоче дати зрозуміти,
що у разі ескалації обом країнам є що втрачати.
Тут, за лаштунками,
не вважають візит спікерки раціональним,
оскільки існує реальна загроза
виникнення другого фронту у Китаї саме тоді,
коли світ зосереджений на війні в Україні.
Китай може обʼєднати свої сили з Росією.
У разі загострення конфлікту
від економічних проблем
потерпатимуть обидві країни регіону.
Зрештою США та Китай раніше хотіли
обʼєднати свої сили щодо багатьох питань:
як боротьба зі змінами клімату, про яку Байден та Сі Цзіньпін
говорили більше двох годин минулого тижня.
Тож тут наголошують на програшній ситуації
для обох країн.
Якщо на демонстрацію сили
у Вашингтоні можуть закрити очі,
то на військову ескалацію реагуватимуть відповідно.
Небезпечна ситуація.
Дякую Вам за інформацію.
Якщо у вас залишились питання
щодо конфлікту у Тайвані,
ви можете їх поставити
у прямому ефірі «ZDFheute-Live» о 19:30
в наших соціальних мережах та у застосунку
Там ви знайдете
більше зручно структурованої інформації.
Наприклад, про військове
і економічне значення Тайваню.
Він був одним із найбільш розшукуваних
терористів світу -
лідер «Аль-Каїди» Айман аль-Завахірі.
США ліквідували його атакою безпілотника
в Афганістані.
Довгі роки аль-Завахірі був другим
після Усами бен Ладена,
брав участь у плануванні та реалізації терористичних актів
11 вересня 2001 року.
Аль-Завахірі був дипломованим лікарем,
тому отримав прізвисько «Лікар терору».
Вашингтон обіцяв нагороду у 25 мільйонів
доларів за його особу.
Більше в репортажі Клаудії Бейтс.
Дим над будинком у Кабулі.
За даними американської розвідки,
лідер терористичної організації «Аль-Каїда»
пішов заліг на дно в домівці своїх родичів
в афганській столиці.
Безпілотник атакував аль-Завахірі,
коли той був на балконі.
Операція планувалася більше шести місяців.
Тепер справедливість перемогла.
Цього лідера терористів більше немає.
Людство не
має більше боятися цього диявольського вбивцю.
Айман аль-Завахірі десятиліттями був
прибічником Усами бен Ладена і
головним стратегом терактів,
скоєних організацією «Аль-Каїда».
Серед них теракти
11 вересня 2001 року
та багато інших атак на США та їх союзників.
Після хаотичного відходу військ США з Афганістану
президент Байден заперечив докори критиків
та стверджував,
що зможе боротися з тероризмом на відстані.
Результат можемо бачити сьогодні.
Незалежно від того, скільки часу це займе,
і наскільки чудова ваша схованка,
якщо ви становите загрозу для нашого народу,
то ми вас знайдемо і ліквідуємо.
За даними США,
будинок, де проживав аль-Завахірі, належав
близькому колезі міністра
внутрішніх справ Афганістану Хаккані,
який є головою іншої терористичної мережі.
Прибічники руху «Талібан» не засвоїли урок.
Відомо, що керівництво «Аль-Каїди»,
оточення аль-Завахірі, продовжувало
тісні стосунки з лідерами «Талібану».
Перед відходом США «Талібан»
пообіцяв розірвати відносини з «Аль-Каїдою».
Що ж, умов угоди дотримано не було.
Перейдемо до новин в Україні.
Полк «Азов» - окремий загін спецпризначення,
що став відомим своїм тривалим
та героїчним захистом Маріуполя.
Верховний суд РФ напередодні визнав
полк терористичною організацією.
Бійці полку змушені
були здатися й покинути металургійний завод.
З того часу вони перебувають у російському полоні.
У зв'язку з тим, що полк «Азов»
прирівняно до терористичної організації,
його бійці можуть бути засуджені
до тривалого ув'язнення
на строк до 20 років.
Сьогодні все більше споживачів стикаються
з підвищенням цін на газ.
Актуальний приклад:
Кельнський постачальник електроенергії
«Rheinenergie» з жовтня стягуватиме плату
на 133% більше.
З огляду на такий розвиток подій
знову почалися
обговорення щодо внутрішніх газових родовищ.
Однак значна їх частина може бути досягнута
лише за допомогою спірного методу -
гідророзриву пласта.
У цьому процесі суміш води, піску та хімічних речовин
під високим тиском
вдавлюється в глибокі шари гірських порід.
Газ може виходити через утворені тріщини
і таким чином видобуватися.
Про можливості та ризики розкаже
Олівер Дойкер.
5% від попиту на природний газ Німеччини
видобуваються всередині країни.
Розрізняють конвенційний та
неконвенційний газ.
Останній залягає
в дуже вузькопористих сланцевих породах
і може бути добутим лише за допомогою спірного методу
гідророзриву пласта, який заборонено в Німеччині.
Галузь готова до видобутку
у разі скасування заборони політиками.
Якщо паралельно із цим промисловість
мобілізує необхідні технології,
то перший сланцевий газ
можна буде видобувати вже за кілька місяців.
Торік було видобуто 5,2 млрд. кубометрів
конвенційного природного газу,
і близько 32,4 млрд. кубометрів
все ще доступні для видобутку.
Запаси неконвенційного газу,
такого, як сланцевий газ,
набагато більші - до 22 600 млрд. кубометрів.
З них 2 300 млрд. кубометрів
є технічно можливо видобути,
але екологи чітко висловлюються проти.
Це не є розумним рішенням для скорочення викидів.
Водночас туди залучатимуться інвестиції,
які ні до чого не приведуть.
Нам потрібні ці інвестиції
для відновлюваних джерел енергії
або енергозбереження.
Крім того, гідророзрив пласта не є екологічно безпечним -,
критикують вчені-енергетики.
Проблема полягає в тому,
що необхідно закачувати хімікати в землю.
Але більша шкода полягає в тому,
що для руйнування породи
доводиться спускатися під землю з шаленим тиском.
Це руйнує структури і
вони не завжди руйнуються контрольованим чином.
Одним із наслідків можуть стати невеликі землетруси,
які вже кілька разів відбувалися у районах видобутку газу.
Чи проводитимуть у Німеччині нові роботи
з гідророзриву пласта?
З політичної точки зору зараз це важко здійснити.
Розробка нових джерел енергії
в умовах кризи - це єдина можливість,
а економія енергії - інша.
Ось чому в Іспанії зараз вжито жорстких заходів.
Так громадські будівлі,
а також універмаги чи аеропорти
влітку можна охолоджувати лише до 27°
та опалювати до максимум
до 19° взимку.
Світло на освітлюваних будівлях
та у вітринах магазинів
мусить бути виключене о 10 вечора.
Наскільки небезпечна мавпяча віспа
і як вона передається?
Німецьке лікарняне товариство
вимагає кращої поінформованості щодо захворювання.
Тим часом зараз лише в Німеччині
налічується понад 2700 інфікованих,
в тому числі двоє підлітків,
як повідомляє сьогодні Інститут Роберта Коха.
Нещодавно в Європі було схвалено вакцину.
Нідерланди вже розпочали вакцинаційну кампанію.
Флоріан Нойганн з репортажем.
Їм довелося два роки робити паузу через коронавірус,
а зараз знову триває гей-парад в Амстердамі.
Але якщо одна пандемія ще не закінчилася,
то наступна вірусна інфекція вже викликає побоювання.
Я такий щасливий! Але зараз,
після коронавірусу, з'явилася мавпяча віспа.
Завтра мені зроблять щеплення.
Я отримав лист-запрошення.
Передається мавпяча віспа від
людини до людини через тісний контакт, наприклад,
статевий.
Можливе також зараження також через
контактні поверхні.
Передача повітряно-крапельним шляхом
вважається малоймовірною.
У службі охорони здоров'я Амстердама зазначають,
що нинішній спалах захворювання
торкається переважно чоловіків,
які мають статеві контакти з чоловіками.
Тому відколи вакцину схвалили,
тут систематично проводять вакцинацію груп ризику.
Ми спеціально запрошуємо чоловіків,
які отримують профілактику проти ВІЛ-інфекції.
Це перша група.
Друга група, де ми виявляємо спалах частіше,-
це ВІЛ-інфіковані чоловіки.
Вони також отримають вакцину.
Проблема у тому, що у всьому світі
спостерігається дефіцит вакцин.
Також тут, у Сан-Франциско в Каліфорнії,
люди годинами чекають на щеплення.
Або в Німеччині.
Наразі ми маємо лише невелику кількість доз вакцин.
Ще 200 000 буде надано найближчим часом.
Але навіть цього буде недостатньо,
щоб вакцинувати всіх людей,
які зараз потребують щеплення.
В Амстердамі зараз використовують
вільні пункти вакцинації від коронавірусу.
Минулого тижня тут було проведено вакцинацію
500 осіб проти мавпячої віспи.
Сінті та роми з усієї Європи
в меморіалі Аушвіц-Біркенау
вшанували пам'ять вбитих нацистами родичів.
Президент Федеральної ради Бодо Рамелоу
попередив, що в багатьох місцях
вони знову стають маргіналами
за умов негласного апартеїду.
З 2015 року 2 серпня є офіційним
Європейським днем пам'яті жертв
Голокосту серед сінті та ромів.
500 000 людей було вбито нацистами.
Підозрюваний «правий» терорист
постав перед Вищим земельним судом у Франкфурті.
Марвін Е. повинен відповісти
за нібито заплановані у Німеччині теракти.
Передбачається, що 20-річний хлопець
із Північного Гессена
намагався заснувати відгалуження
правого терористичного угруповання
"Відділ ядерної зброї" і завербувати послідовників.
Крім того, він звинувачується в порушенні
Закону про зброю та вибухові речовини.
Її прізвище говорить саме за себе:
Труде Унрух багато років поспіль
захищала права людей похилого віку в Німеччині.
Як стало відомо, що ця суперечлива політична діячка
померла у віці 96 років.
З 70-х років вона була символічною фігурою
асоціації захисту людей похилого віку «Сіра Пантера».
Наприкінці 80-х вона три роки засідала
в Бундестазі і боролася
за базову пенсію та вільний вибір
догляду за людьми похилого віку.
Наразі 13 клубів першої Прем'єр-ліги
дійшли до 2-го раунду Кубка Німеччини з футболу,
включаючи «Айнтрахт Франкфурт». Крістін, тобі слово.
За чотири дні до старту матчу Бундесліги проти «Баварії»
переможці Ліги Європи
з новачком Маріо Гетце вже демонструють гарну динаміку.
У Магдебурзі перемогу з рахунком 4:0
святкував «Айнтрахт».
Маріо Гетце грає під номером 27
у швидкий подвійний пас
з Філіпом Костичем.
Команда з Магдебурга,
що перейшла в другий дивізіон, захоплена зненацька.
Гості з Франкфурта виходять вперед.
Четверта хвилина - Даїчі Камада.
Після того, як Кевін Трапп
сфолив на Андреасі Мьоллер з Магдебурга,
Гетце робить наступний блискучий пас.
Дебютуючи у складі «Айнтрахта»,
бомбардир чемпіонату світу 2014 вже точно знає,
як ввести в гру Ансгара Кнауффа.
Воротар Домінік Рейманн на місці.
Але Джеспер Ліндстром може з ними щось зробити:
2:0 на користь Франкфурта у перерві.
Після цього Камада знову забиває точний гол -
рахунок 3:0.
іНа 90-й хвилині Лукас Аларіо забиває гол після
попередньої підготовки Коло Мохалі.
4:0 наприкінці виступу «Айнтрахта»
з Маріо Гетце у головній ролі.
Через два дні після фіналу Чемпіонату Європи
німецькі футболістки
здобули ще одне велике визнання.
УЄФА обрала п'ятьох гравчинь
з команди Мартіни Фосс-Текленбург
до «найкращої команди турніру».
Вони пропустили свій дев'ятий титул чемпіонів Європи,
але все одно були переконливими.
Відразу п'ять гравчинь збірної Німеччини
увійшли до складу уславленої «почесної команди»,
обраної експертною комісією УЄФА.
Серед них Александра Попп,
капітанка збірної Німеччини, що забила 6 голів,
а також захисниця Джулія Гвінн,
яка дійшла до фіналу чемпіонату Європи 2022
після розриву хрестоподібної зв'язки.
Ще одна захисниця була удостоєна такої честі:
32-річна Марина Хегерінг на прізвисько «Машина».
Незважаючи на коронавірусну інфекцію
та пропущені півфінал та фінал,
Клару Бюль також обрали до числа «одинадцятки».
І нарешті, Лена Обердорф,
яку називають «талантом століття»,
а їй лише 20 років.
Серед «одинадцятки» -
чотири гравчинці команди-чемпіона з Англії.
Завтра очікується спека -
максимальні температури
перевищать 30°,
а післязавтра спека досягне свого піку.
Детальніше про погоду від Каті Хорнеффер.
«Heute journal» з Крістіаном Зіверсом о 21.45.
Дякуємо за перегляд, гарного вечора!
Добрий вечір, зараз, у серпні,
дні поступово стають коротшими,
а ночі довшими.
Це помітно рано вранці, коли туман або імла
можуть трохи затримуватися,
наприклад, уздовж Дунаю,
а також у низьких гірських масивах.
Зазвичай через годину-дві
туман зникає, і тоді з'являються
в основному нешкідливі, малі купчасті хмари
або іноді вищі вуалеві хмари.
Зараз стає спекотно і тепло надходить
із південно-західної Європи.
В Іспанії сьогодні знову було 43°,
на півдні Франції 36°, а у нас тут 31°.
Наступної ночі можна добре провітритися,
оскільки навіть у районі Рейн-Майн температура
до раннього ранку опуститься до 19°,
а у Верхньому Пфальці
або у передгір'ї Альп - до 12°.
Якщо ви все ще не можете спокійно спати,
подивіться на небо
і помітьте падаючу зірку.
Це Персеїди, хоча їх пік буде досягнутий
лише наприкінці наступного тижня.
Завтра теж буде багато сонця,
лише невеликі купчасті хмари,
що приносять мало тіні і без дощу.
Тож тут буде спекотно:
Температура підніметься від 30° до 36°.
Тільки на Північному морі не так спекотно - 28-29°.
У четвер температура повітря підніметься до 39°,
а потім розпочнуться сильні грози,
які витіснять спеку з Німеччини.
Гарного вечора!